sure so just to start off so so we have
the context this is the demo we have
here at e3 that we're letting people
play just so everyone knows this is this
is a living game we still have a ways to
go to finish off the game and completely
polish it so we might see some hiccups
along the way but we fully assume that
we're super proud to be here to show it
off we've been working a long time on
this and and it's finally exciting to to
be able to to show it and have people
play it and send us feedback so so here
we're gonna go Carl is gonna show off
his skills
he's ghazal Russell in this guild is
ghazal skills and here we're gonna start
with a camp so these camps these are
military locations he's gonna use ten
new right that's right I knew sending
three yes she's a beauty she's a great
scout
so right now Carl's using her to to tag
the enemies but also tagging
opportunities in the in the camp now the
question might be why would someone
infiltrate such a location outside of
quests so there is a quest actually
takes place here and the demo we've
disabled the quest so that we can focus
on the world and what happens with the
world later on there's going to be more
streams with quests so that we can kind
of spread the the love of the content
but for now we're just kind of cutting
loose in the open world and gonna see
what is in store for us here at this
camp
now with the tagging I'm noticing you
know one of the new features here is
that levels are popping up out for the
enemy's heads as you are tagging I so
what what can the player read into those
levels as to what kind of challenge
they're going to face yeah so by going a
lot more action-rpg what's happening
here is that right now by ik is level 20
and he's facing off against enemies that
are at an equivalent challenge and so
this would be considered a fair you know
challenge fight in this part of the
world and we'll see that as we'll see
later on there's another camp with
enemies our level 25 and you'll see that
the feedback slightly different this is
to really clarify to people levels
matter gear matters
taking on higher-level enemies it's
doable mm-hmm but they're tougher not
only in SATs but they're also tougher in
behavior so the higher level they are
they have more capacities more ability
stronger weapons so you might want to
think twice before taking them back for
it get some better gear or just light
your arrows on fire oh really what are
you doing there Carl I think I'm gonna
have caused a little bonfire down here
why not because it's not hot enough just
a little more warm from the bonfire
speaking of which my feet are on fire we
are in the middle of the Edit it is
really hot is offer for your
entertainment we where is the equivalent
of method acting
is you know we Hayek is warm right now
you think that hood is like you know
yeah I'm cool that hood is warm and and
I will say for the fans out there who Oh
little contact my office
at act the horse he's got a snack on oh
it is a distraction he's been teaching
up for a while so that's something that
we fully embrace in here so all the
NPC's of the world all the humans all
the animals they have a full life in the
world they have needs they have wants
animals you know they hunt they sleep
they find shade so in this case this
line has been captured and been put in a
cage and at this point it becomes an
opportunity for the player it'll you
can't always guarantee it but um okay so
these guys are they sent something they
were seeing a lion getting released they
to see him kind of hard to miss that one
yeah a fire there you go girl
something's get all the Cemal down
nice job Carl there we go so we just
knocked up a bow so this is something
that's really important in an assassin's
creed origins it's gear um well he was
he was so kind to you why should I think
it's like no real lions were hurt out of
the frying pan into the fire so so we
picked up a bow and we saw that it was a
it was a blue bow which means that it's
a common weapon so rarities do matter in
this game yeah the more rare the
equipment is the more attributes it has
the more properties it has so as opposed
to just just does some more damage it
cannot have other properties like what
does an example exactly so so other
properties could be things like
poison-tipped you know uh being able to
generate adrenaline adrenaline is a
concept it's a resource in the combat
system that allows byuk to unleash a
fury of attacks or or just devastating
overpowering attacks and you can build
adrenaline through the combat system and
some weapons charge differently than
others so this is part of the depth of
the combat that we want players to mess
around with and this is a whole new
combat system you guys match up it's way
different than the feeling before of
that's right yeah take on a poor guy oh
poor guy oh you you can cover some
ground so this guy's a commander that's
the the gold icon oh not for long
there we go there yeah good so there we
go so killed here we found a second bow
so in a military location military
locations are great for finding
equipment and new gear
aside from flank West these are also
places to to be able to upgrade bike
with new new weapons loot oh here we
found
whoa oh we leveled up I would be writing
ability points so we'll check that out
in a second
check it out now yeah and we found a
shield oh cool
thank you so here we're looking at sort
of the the skill tree and I'm seeing
three different branches yeah it's it's
more of a graph what that means is there
are flavors so on the one side we see
here is the the master seer this is more
the abilities that are aligned with
manipulation so manipulating the
environment animals and NPCs in the
center we have the warrior aspect which
is really delving deep into fight and
the hunter aspect which is more the
stealthy approach of being an assassin
or being a ranger and the idea is
players can dedicate themselves or go
through the graph however they want
that's why it's a graph because they can
actually kind of spread themselves as
they wish they can clearly craft their
own their own assassin and you can even
focus on one area if you want to be the
absolute ultimate warrior yeah you can
you can dedicate yourself so the last
ability on each graph you can keep
pumping points into it so you can really
become that super powerful archetype
that you wish to play you just got to
chase down a fluorescent outfit and
you're good to go so what kind of player
would you be ash what's your personal
favorite style personally well we should
we should get Carl to to buy something
here go for the enhanced forever enhance
warrior bow the warrior bow super cool
we haven't seen it yet so maybe we
should switch to it if we can yeah we
did pick up a few new bows right check
out the new gear I got yeah definitely
check out the new gear so in terms of my
my style I would I would say I'm
somewhere between a hunter and warrior I
can't choose one or the other I
sometimes for first off sometimes for
just duking it out with the guys that's
my style but that's one thing we wanted
to cater to is that we have a lot of
fans who either play stealth or play
pure combat it depends I wanted to give
them a control over that yeah so here we
can see that Carl put on a new bow you
also had a new shield around the shield
put on the shield new everything with
new bow new shield really gonna be
better
it's way better so the shield adds to
the players resistance it was quite
significant and we can see it has a
property which is that when you block a
hit you generate adrenaline so the idea
is with gear you can actually start
crafting again the way you fight the way
you stealth we can see the crafting at
the bottom there so just just like
combat there's no longer this concept
that you can one-shot assassinate just
anybody enemies that are higher level
you'll do stealth damage but if you want
to one-shot them be that truly sole
assassin you have to craft better hidden
blades hard at it or and now we're going
full of boat ride yeah you're trying to
cool down in the sea which I wish I
could do right now because I am on fire
pretty hot so this is the amazing tech
Singapore has been working on the water
I think it's some of the most beautiful
water in anyways it's absolutely
beautiful
it's completely seamless we can at some
point will dive underneath but for now
you know we have an island here let's
maybe at some point explore the island
well this lake is pretty big yeah can we
just get a sort of look at how how big
this is so this is what I go look at
this lake yeah I don't know I'm gonna
the the draw distance are absolutely
stunning
yeah this is for you folks watching this
is running on the Xbox one X yeah
it's absolutely beautiful it's really
allowing us to showcase what we can push
with our engine the beauty of the world
we really want to do Egypt justice and
and and and show it off show off our
artists offer our technical technical
people our programmers who bring this to
life it's gorgeous so here we can see
some boats in the distance this this
bigger ship here there's there's always
opportunities a lot of the world is
alive
no fishermen are out catching fish
they'll take their there
- to shore - docks take them to the
markets go home and sleep at night and
there's always opportunities for the
player here
all right out for a little swim and you
mentioned underwater uh let's take a
break sure yeah we go look uh you know I
heard you something dangerous often the
horizon there oh yes uh yeah what is
that a hippo oh man to be awful sorry
looks pretty friendly let's get closer
see what happens a good idea very good
idea or not all has a great track record
for this animals so nothing could go
wrong
what's your get you've heard about his
stories from Singapore ID so here so
this is the location the reason there's
loot here the question might be why is
their loot here there's actually this
island it's it's where the Ptolemies so
the the guard force he they use this
island as a way to to stop to take a
break to to actually refill on some of
their stocks and so here we can see
there's actually a guard on the other
side who's been killed by what I don't
know but I need be the hippo not in here
oh no he's a good guy hey my nice - nice
dude well I gotta spin it got a beer use
the sphere swish this okay let's switch
yeah cuz that's the thing we've seen
sort of that uh
that short curved sword in actual fish
yeah but there's there there is a
variety of weapons and the sort of the
reach of the longer weapons is going to
affect how you are in combat exactly so
so we have a ton of types of weapons so
eight melee weapons four types of bows
and this is just the type then within
them there's levels attributes
properties and all that stuff and of
course it's a completely simply seamless
system here or using the bow in water
you should get in closer call and see
what happened Mica's go tomorrow if Carl
was good he can shoot those birds down
all the problems right now we're gonna
do with this angry beast
they're just trying to see hi okay you
know I feel like you're engaging it on
its home turf like maybe they're slower
on land you don't want to
and he's using the smoker your smack at
the hippo is oh that's workable
what if it's amaro now you've got him
angry he just wanted to say hi
oh mama Carl's in even more trouble yeah
keep suckering inner fish yes yeah no
hippos were harmed in the making of them
no it's no actual hippos making of
assassins this one's being armed oh
there we go alright so when you lose a
hippo what are you what are you gaining
from this beast so what was the purpose
of this magic I think you would say that
sentence so animals so the fauna of
Egypt wolf okay
throw that guy on this boat yeah we're
guy oh this is everybody there's a hippo
just over there careful huh you can use
the corpse as a float you'll be fine all
style this is girl style
so obviously Egypt it's rich it's very
well known for its its fauna its its
wildlife and we needed to represent that
properly here and then we have to say
well it matters to the player on some
level so this is part of the progression
system so you gain materials that you
would use to to craft some of your gear
mm-hmm so so that's oh you're just a
shit-jerk shoe Carl its military it's
alright these are military dude
Oh put cheese on fire now okay
ooh fire on a boat that's uh that's a
recipe for disaster
I like it the fisherman's coming in
dangerously oh boy it's someone else
mixing it up over there we go for me
though he knew that his boat was in
trouble I'll bet he okay just leave him
to tread water yeah so you know what if
this situation is slightly different
guys just along for the ride
he's funny you like whatever happening
guys just chillin
the thing is vyak is a Magi they are
protectors of Egypt
they're protectors of the the Egyptian
Way of life and Egyptians have a high
respect for my guys and they go to them
for help this is actually feeds into the
questing system actually so as a Magi he
respects him he's gonna let him take his
book for a ride you do you buy a cue do
you set boats on fire I like it too cuz
he's not like obviously the boats
important to that dude like it's
probably his livelihood he's like look
man you kiddin you can take this
wherever you want but I'm I need it when
you're done unproven he'll even wait a
bit eventually he'll leave but he'll
wait a bit for now he's watching me
Kevin so courteous like encasing you to
getaway vehicle I'm here bro exactly
exactly so so here this is this is
another military camp but this one's
slightly different this one's a wharf
here what we what we wanted to show is
just what it's like to take on enemies
that are much higher level so here we'll
see some guards so there's some in the
front gate there so level 25 you see
that the badge is red which is kind of
telling the player yes you can try you
can try try your best you crying Adam
give it a shot but it's gonna be a very
difficult fight because you're you're
not at their level just yet eventually
with by going through quest by
completing locations in the world you
will level up enough so I would
recommend just yeah Karl I think Karl
what's your plan here are you gonna take
this you're gonna have it let's go this
guy's no he's he looks vulnerable so
let's try a headshot he's alone let's
try a headshot see how much damage it
does oh goodness
it's not gonna do a lot SWAT a fly yeah
yeah I don't know yeah just a little
scratch get up on him all right got this
gun this year Oh a native close quarters
and Karl oh boy here we go
I believe in you Karl you can kill him
he can take him honestly he can do it
Karl
Karl's been practicing very good at the
game oh goodness
yeah we got him like a stun almost
happening is that a heavy hit on Jordan
you get enough effort
it's okay yeah - it's from me okay oh
look the game is live yeah you know is
this real gameplay that we take you know
we take games very seriously in the
sense of we you know we want this to be
the
patient of the game as it is wrong
players to see where it is today so yes
in a demo playthrough Carl died rub it
in ash in front of everybody about my
lesson and I'll just keep moving on the
level 25 - hi let's give them a wide
berth now and uh so you're coming in
your books are leaving the wharf and
coming oh hey buddy yeah so cuz I fell
for for his mounts and does this horse
have a name or is it with no name
not this horse is named a moon ray I
would ring oh he's going question you to
force
so sin who is as our eagle companion in
this case though we wanted that mounts
was something that the player can
actually collect more and more mounds
purchase more and more mounts and we
have many different types of mounts so
there's horses a types of beautiful
horses but also camels and eventually
chariots emerald yeah and they all have
their value and so so you can actually
have different types of horses send you
being the the eagle companion that stays
with you through the journey so there we
go so we have we have this beautiful
black horse here goes the camel ax
values it attack cuz I hear they do it
that's good attack know but I but you
can rear with the horse can we were the
horse the camel get the hooves in there
so we're sort of skirting the shoreline
here and you know this is you guys have
built as you were saying in the
presentation this is a country you know
this is not just one city so what kind
of region are we in yeah actually before
before we go in so so here we found you
Mary which is a which is a port village
actually maybe a last call to go to the
the map show him go to the map just to
kind of give
a general spacing of the world so so
where so this is the like that we've
seen with Sena move we keep zooming out
consuming that this is the this is the
the aspects the demo the lake is where
the demo takes place since we were
riding a bit north of it earlier how did
we start around here yeah that's why
that's how we unfuck the world by
visiting the world you want fog it but
just to give a breath of this country
that we've built my goodness yeah I move
around just to show it's slow yeah
that's it keeps normos it's absolutely
massive up to Alexandria and the north a
luxurious desert the Nile Delta the Giza
Plateau Memphis the ancient city of
Memphis and it goes on then there's Phi
um a crocodile palace down in the south
gonca world police yes yes reality I
like that place thieves land who do you
going on does anybody ever go there
really honest people I don't ever wanna
go daring players should go there it's
tough enough for them so just to give an
idea that that we you know this is a
country Egypt is it's such a majestic
setting and we've dreamed of going to
this place and so when we started and we
decided we're going to Egypt we we
understood that it was gonna be you know
a labor of love it was gonna it was
going to push us to develop new
technologies to build such a crazy big
world and then to even populate the
world with all these people that
actually have agendas and purpose mm-hmm
for example these these people over here
are being attracted by an event if
guards look at it Oh God oh my goodness
Oh Egypt is hard Egypt with a park like
this investigate priests what does the
void don't deserve this this has nothing
to do with you
back away the boy will get what he
deserves
aye sir so back I stole him I am a silly
boy what are you accused oh I was
charged with ferrying to Gold sold eggs
to cocoa Dino bonus just out of pods my
ship sank by the lighthouse I almost
drowned
is that shoes what lost I didn't steal
them silence and you sit back sanity
wait
do not threaten me never I am a Magi if
the boy speaks the truth I will find
your gold sore back
if you lies is used to deal with so here
we we got a little bit of a taste of
bikes personality and his attitude
towards these masks eating mask priests
that have used their power and this is a
side quest so our players can expect
this this type of quality no cinematix
great characters in the optional Casas
in the side quest and we have hundreds
of stories to tell
Egypt was a really wonderful place then
we found so much amazing stories that we
wanted a way to be able to tell them in
the quest structure allowed us to do
that but again we're saving the quest
stuff for four other streams for for
youtubers out there so so for now we'll
continue with open tomorrow dannegan
yeah folks are just joining us we're
playing Assassin's Creed origins on the
Xbox one X with Ashe and Carl from the
Assassin's Creed origins dev team I'm
Chris this is Hany and we'll be doing
this for about ten more minutes so stick
around we've got plenty of open-world
stuff to show you
and some explorations here as senyu
scouts out some more locations so ticket
girl so here actually I'm gonna ask Carl
to not stop this one the reason we're
showing these different locations
different camps and warps is actually we
wanted to show a bit of stealth we want
to show a bit of flight so I'm gonna ask
Carl all right well we got another label
here p-meter some redemption oh yeah
okay so complete this Carl
we were given the choice of a liar I
come out the bushes are you going in
with the spear I'll just shoot him in
the chest first wake him up dad wake up
oh here we go
okay alright dodge come on call redeem
yourself boom nice job so far point to
show that he's dead the versatility of
the fight we can you can take out your
bow there go dynamically in the Iseman
Oh bravo Bravo
all right now is he close to filling up
his adrenaline meter here yes seals like
that might be helpful get in there it's
getting there I'm trying to use it on
the big dude he is humongous there we go
okay just just get in there I'm
there we go okay boy oh boy okay here we
go to see car pop oh nice yeah good very
good
mister that was oh you done good car on
the road that time nice nice job Carl
he'll thank you thank you alright now
give us a little broader context who are
these dudes that byuk is dispatching
with such ash so so this is where we're
in their in their era the Ptolemies so
these are Ptolemaic guards they work for
the people that bake is is is going
after and I say going after effectively
byuk is unraveling mystery and he
doesn't know who who these characters
are that he's after and so he comes to
this place he's actually looking for a
contact to gain some info to lead him to
eventually his targets and these are the
Ptolemy's guards who work for these
people byuk being an Egyptian a Magi he
doesn't have a very good alignment with
these people the second thing they
represent the evil forces that are
destroying his homeland so anyway so
these are the people he's after this
area of the world just to say if we take
a look around yeah crawl this is a
beautiful shot of the world I'll give us
a slope han here so this is this is good
there's a reach high point so we can get
a better view from there yeah so we're
gonna do a view point a view point
well do where your point justice for a
sec we're seeing you know some serious
climbing here a hallmark of the
Assassin's Creed franchise but that rock
didn't have any like obvious handhold
hell holds on it like what's the
approach to climbing in origins so the
climbing actually before before we
synchronize just to look around so
pretty so the climbing and origins it's
so so first we've revamped the controls
the fluidity of the character we've got
a lot of positive feedback already from
the people who played the bill that feel
like the assassin is really responsive
listening to them doing what they want
and we push that to the climbing where
we said you know what we should be able
to climb any surface we want so so we've
created a tech for-for-for bike when
he's climbing to be able to put his
hands and fur holds into crevices and so
on on any surface
so effectively to be able to climb
anywhere we wanted you know as the most
seamless experience that we can have you
can see the world is absolutely
beautiful see that oh that distance that
top peak in the distance you know we
could just go there at some point if we
wish to swimming by boat by camel
whatever and money and your secrets up
there for us there's really love secrets
really cool discoveries to find here why
don't why don't we synchronize say or
the world is you know kudos to our
artists our engineers our technical
artists you know this this world is
something absolutely and you know so
synchronizing you know historically sort
of a way to learn more about an area
sort of clear the fog from an area I
mentioned earlier the fog there's might
you just you're just traveling through
in the area yeah exactly so we wanted to
keep the idea of the we wanted to keep
the viewpoints as an homage to to the
series there it is there it is there it
is maybe we can explore a bit walk
through yeah yeah a little bit just to
give a flavor of the the village life
villages are great places to to pick up
quests to go to shops to and obviously
there are many quests inside villages
these are hubs of content but anyway so
we're actually we're in a red zone right
now
uh so now my fleeing technology yeah I'd
recommend fleeing maybe I mean are you
keep quiet
are you can fight he's feeling strong
from his last encounter yep
he's digging that's real company thing
MLA and now we're changed busting out
the Warriors bow here that was a skill
we unlocked earlier oh yeah oh yeah good
point good point sir supportable so the
warrior bow it's effectively our yeah
our shotgun bow
he shoots five arrows at Waimea oh my
god deadly beautiful very efficient to
choose five arrows at once so when we
talk about attributes and properties you
can actually find bows that you can
actually have more arrows on them you
can set them on fire by default mm-hmm
so this this actual this compound here
it's actually part of a part of a quest
I don't want to ruin the quest for
people but this is somebody's home
that's been let's say confiscated and
bike will eventually have to have to
help those people
that's a porcupine that's that's a lot
of arrows but you can recover it looks
like you're recovering yeah yeah you can
pick up your arrows that and that ranged
combat that focus on sort of you know
assassins have had ranged weapons in the
past before but with the bows and
origins you guys are really trying to
expand that yeah it's a it's a
full-blown third-person shooter on that
element its we really wanted that the
playstyles we push so range combat melee
stealth that this stuff feels authentic
and if you just want to focus on that
that the game will fully support it and
will go deep into that so we've really
pushed ourselves to to develop these
gameplays the shooting feels great the
bows feel amazing and there's a bunch of
bows we haven't shown there's the
predator bow which is kind of like a
sniper yeah this is such a great way to
wrap this up like we just saw a cat in
ancient Egypt combination and and you
know what caps are very important in
ancient Egypt it so so here look so see
okay look so systemically you know as I
said animals really live in this world
he and so this cat has for some reason
an affection towards by he loves you or
she or she sticking around she loves me
we put a lot of effort on animals and
cheese than what they do in the world I
love that she appeared at the end of
this stream this is amazing moment yes
actually this has been so great Karl
thank you for showing off the game I
there's a lot more to come this week and
but it must be really exciting for you
guys you know it's been a long journey
for us it's absolutely wonderful to be
able to show off the game and have
people play it get their feedback see
their excitement I'm super super proud
of the team and and what we've achieved
cool
those two to the Singapore team to the
Montreal team to all that all the teams
that are working on this game all over
there were many people supporting us
it's it's a really wonderful exciting
time for us and I can't wait for our
fans to play this absolutely and they'll
get to play it at e3 here but later this
year October 27th is for ETS October
27th October 27th on ps4 Pro ps4 xbox pc
and of course a launch title for Xbox
one X fantastic well if you folks want
more Assassin's Creed origins here at e3
there's going to be streams keep it
tuned to Ubisoft social channels to find
out when and where those are if you want
more Assassin's Creed right now you can
head to be soft YouTube channel and
check out the behind the scenes video
from the UV blog and for all the awesome
games here revealed during that
incredible conference now Ubisoft comm
that's where it's at so on behalf of
handy Carl ash I'm Chris waters thanking
all of you for watching and have a great
week peace you have a grade III
you
[Music]